Consider the problem
of using voltages
to represent the information
in a black-and-white image.
Each (x,y) point in the image
has an associated intensity:
black is the weakest
intensity, white the strongest.
An obvious voltage-based
representation
would be to encode the intensity
as a voltage, say 0V for black,
1V for white, and some
intermediate voltage
for intensities in-between.
First question: how much
information is there
at each point in the image?
The answer depends on how well
we can distinguish intensities
or, in our case, voltages.
If we can distinguish
arbitrarily small differences,
then there’s potentially an
infinite amount of information
in each point of the image.
But, as engineers, we
suspect there’s a lower-bound
on the size of
differences we can detect.
To represent the same amount
of information that can be
represented with N bits, we
need to be able to distinguish
a total 2^N voltages in
the range of 0V to 1V.
For example, for N = 2, we’d
need to be able to distinguish
between four possible voltages.
That doesn’t seem too hard —
an inexpensive volt-meter would
let us easily distinguish
between 0V, 1/3V, 2/3V and 1V.
In theory, N can be
arbitrarily large.
In practice, we know it would
be quite challenging to make
measurements with, say, a
precision of 1-millionth
of a volt and probably
next to impossible
if we wanted a precision
of 1-billionth of a volt.
Not only would the equipment
start to get very expensive
and the measurements
very time consuming,
but we’d discover that
phenomenon like thermal noise
would confuse what we mean
by the instantaneous voltage
at a particular time.
So our ability to encode
information using voltages
will clearly be
constrained by our ability
to reliably and
quickly distinguish
the voltage at particular time.
To complete our project of
representing a complete image,
we’ll scan the image in some
prescribed raster order —
left-to-right, top-to-bottom
— converting intensities
to voltages as we go.
In this way, we can
convert the image
into a time-varying
sequence of voltages.
This is how the original
televisions worked:
the picture was encoded
as a voltage waveform that
varied between the
representation for black
and that for white.
Actually the range
of voltages was
expanded to allow
the signal to specify
the end of the horizontal
scan and the end of an image,
the so-called sync signals.
We call this a “continuous
waveform” to indicatuld
have to be made of precision
components and run in
precisely-controlled physical
environments
— hard to accomplish when
we consider the multitude
of environments and the
modest cost expectations
for the systems
we want to build.
So although this definition
has an appealing mathematical
simplicity, it’s not workable
on practical grounds.
This one gets a big red “X”.
In our second attempt, we’ll
introduce two threshold
voltages: V_L and V_H.
Voltages less than or equal to
V_L will be interpreted as 0,
and voltages greater
than or equal to V_H
will be interpreted as 1.
The range of voltages
between V_L and V_H is called
the “forbidden zone”, where we
are forbidden to ask for any
particular behavior
of our digital system.
A particular system
can interpret
a voltage in the forbidden
zone as either a 0 or a 1,
and is not even required
to be consistent
in its interpretation.
In fact the system
is not required
to produce any interpretation at
all for voltages in this range.
How does this help?
Now we can build a
quick-and-dirty voltage-to-bit
converter, say by using a
high-gain op-amp and reference
voltage somewhere in
the forbidden zone
to decide if a given voltage
is above or below the threshold
voltage.
This reference voltage doesn’t
have to be super-accurate,
so it could be
generated with, say,
a voltage divider built
from low-cost 10%-accurate
resistors.
The reference could
change slightly
as the operating temperature
varied or the power supply
voltage changed, and so on.
We only need to guarantee
the correct behavior
of our converter for voltages
below V_L or above V_H.
This representation is pretty
promising and we’ll tentatively
give it a green
checkmark for now.
After a bit more discussion,
we’ll need to make one more
small tweak before we get
to where we want to go.expect the
output image to look like?
Well, the COPY blocks don’t
change the image and there are
an even number of INVERTING
blocks, so, in theory,
the output image should be
identical to the input image.
But in reality, the output
image isn’t a perfect copy
of the input.
It’s slightly fuzzy, the
intensities are slightly off
and it looks like sharp changes
in intensity have been smoothed
out, creating a blurry
reproduction of the original.
What went wrong?
Why doesn’t theory
match reality?
Perhaps the COPY and INVERTING
blocks don’t work correctly?
That’s almost certainly true,
in the sense that they don’t
precisely obey the mathematical
description of their behavior.
Small manufacturing variations
and differing environmental
conditions will cause each
instance of the COPY block
to produce not V volts
for a V-volt input,
but V+epsilon volts, where
epsilon represents the amount
of error introduced
during processing.
Ditto for the INVERTING block.
The difficulty is that in our
continuous-value representation
of intensity, V+epsilon is a
perfectly correct output value,
just not for a V-volt input!
In other words, we can’t
tell the difference between
a slightly corrupted signal
and a perfectly valid signal
for a slightly different image.
More importantly — and this is
the real killer — the errors
accumulate as the encoded
image passes through the system
of COPY and INVERTING blocks.
The larger the
system, the larger
the amount of accumulated
processing error.
This doesn’t seem so good.
It would be awkward,
to say the least,
if we had to have rules about
how many computations could
be performed on
encoded information
before the results became
too corrupted to be usable.
You would be correct
if you thought
this meant that
the theory we used
to describe the operation
of our system was imperfect.
We’d need a very complicated
theory indeed to capture all
the possible ways in which the
output signal could differ from
its expected value.
Those of us who are
mathematically minded might
complain that “reality
is imperfect”.
This is going a bit far though.
Reality is what it
is and, as engineers,
we need to build our
systems to operate reliably
in the real world.
So perhaps the real
problem lies in how we
chose to engineer the system.
In fact, all of
the above are true!
Noise and inaccuracy
are inevitable.
We can’t reliably reproduce
infinite information.
We must design our system to
tolerate some amount of error
if it is to process
information reliably.
Basically, we need to find a way
to notice that errors have been
introduced by a processing
step and restore
the correct value before
the errors have a chance
to accumulate.
How to do that is
our next topic.